you know it was april fool's day when
the
proposals came out so some people
thought it was an april fool's gag but
the chiefs have
actually proposed that running backs
tight ends receivers linebackers
defensive backs be allowed to wear
single digits and there are plenty of
nfl players who wore single digits in
college who
love the development retweeted our story
with all sorts of great comments
and even orlando brown says that the
offensive lineman
should get dibs on the single digit
numbers they would be excluded as with
the defensive linemen
but plenty of players that there will be
if this ever happens can you imagine
the effort that they're gonna have to
engage in to decide who gets what number
cause everybody's gonna want the single
digit numbers
you're gonna have running backs
receivers tight ends defensive backs and
linebackers all clamoring for nine
single-digit numbers so our draft today
players who would look the best
with single-digit numbers now or in the
past
shireen i'll give you the first pick
there's so many good ones mike and i
want to know why the number two is so
popular but it is popular so i'm going
to start there with dion
sanders because number two at florida
state is retired and it's retired for
dion sanders
he wore of course 21 for the 49ers
cowboys and the washington football team
here's your trivia question since we
didn't have it mike what number did he
wear for the ravens and why didn't he
wear
21 wow
uh he wore what did he wear did he wear
24 because chris mcallister had 21.
you're right about chris mcallister he
wore 37 but that's the reason he didn't
wear 21 but
was because of chris mcallister but he
looked great
thanks matt he looked great in that two
jersey and i think he would look great
in the two jersey in the nfl if he'd
been allowed to wear it mike
all right and that's an obvious one that
would have been my first pick the next
pick
reggie bush and the number five because
this whole debate
started in 2006 when the ubiquitous
mike ornstein was representing reggie
bush for marketing purposes and was
making
an aggressive push to get the nfl to
change its rules
then so that reggie bush could continue
to wear number five
the nfl said no he wore number 25 but
bring back reggie and put him in number
five
he's the guy this rule was made for they
should call it
the reggie bush rule even though it's 15
years after the fact
yes indeed i can see him in that number
two and will look great
in the nfl wearing that number
next round you're up number two
is number two again again number two
i'm gonna have all number twos i think
today charles woodson he won the heisman
and number two right
remember the heisman pose that he made
at michigan
and then he got to the nfl and he had to
play and 24 with the raiders and 21 with
the packers he played 18 seasons in the
pro football hall of fame
great player but i think you would look
much better in the number two in the nfl
mike
yeah i agree with you there and again i
don't know what it is about number two
but
but and i think it's just there was an
article in the new york times a couple
of years ago
about how college players want the
single-digit numbers and the
competitions they have the things they
do to get the single-digit numbers
for whatever reason players are smitten
with that that's why i think it caught
so much fire yesterday because it's off
limits for anyone except quarterbacks
and kickers
in the nfl if they do this there's gonna
be a lot of guys that want it i'm gonna
go jerome bettis number six at notre
dame
36 in the nfl but you know a guy that
big you almost wouldn't be able to see
the number
a little six in the middle of this
gigantic torso
but uh to see that guy rumbling down the
field in the single digit number would
have just been awesome
and and again uh a rule that uh that uh
you know is
is too late for some of these guys but
bettis would have been awesome in six
and i'm gonna say with the number two
again mike i'm gonna go with derek henry
because he wore number two at alabama
uh and he wore number two during his
rookie camp if you remember in the
preseason and then of course the nfl
made him change into a different number
and
and now he has 22 and he says that's a
tribute to
a former alabama running back who was
killed in a car crash they were very
very close
had met at the nike camp and that's the
reason he wears that number 22 now so i
will be curious
if he's allowed to change number if he
changes to two but
think of all the jersey sales mike if a
guy like derek henry changes from 22 to
2 how much jersey sales they're going to
have
just for these guys changing numbers and
i'm glad you made that point i almost
wrote about this last night
maybe i will now because i remember
there was a time
when players would propose changing
their numbers the league
actually said you've got to pay
wholesale cost of all the jerseys that
have already been made with your prior
number
and you have to do that before we let
you change your number
and plenty of guys said i'm sticking
with the number that i have thank you
very much i'm not writing that check
for something like this i think the
folks at nike say
just give those other jerseys away for
free we're going to sell a hell of a lot
more
if you've got single digit numbers for
these star players so i think that it
would not be an issue
this time around um i'm going to go less
less obvious than the ones we've done so
far but
uh for the folks who followed the
minnesota vikings specifically in the
mid
80s and into the early 90s anthony
carter put him in number one
like he wore at michigan and the thing
about anthony carter
he had he had the strangest build of any
football player i can remember
he was just all arms and legs but he was
only five ten
and he had this short torso where i can
remember games where
the bottom of his number the eight and
the one were actually tucked into his
pants
that's how that's how he just this frame
was so different
but uh he should have been in number one
all of mine are historical guys but
but yeah i the and and you know that
there will be receivers out there
and what kind of deals are going to be
done on teams where there's already
a kicker or a quarterback who wears
number one it's going to open a new
universe of negotiations
between players for numbers that may
already be claimed
that they would like to get their hands
on if it happens i don't think it's
going to happen
i think this is one of those that is too
outside the box maybe it happened a few
years from now
but i'd be shocked if there's 23 teams
that will say let's do it unless they
see how much money they can make off of
jersey sales and
maybe that's the impetus for it that's
what it'll have to take mike is
the money they'll make it always comes
down to money and i think we're gonna do
round four
so i'm gonna go away i don't have any
more this kind of takes me away
you don't have any more well i'm going
to go with deandre hopkins because he
was number six at clemson
so i'm gonna go with the andre hopkins i
think he would look great
in that number six again now he's given
multiple reasons
why he now wears the number 10 he
initially said
he wore it as a tribute to soccer great
lionel messi
and then he came back and said he
did it because a cousin of his served 10
years in prison
and he didn't think it was right that he
got 10 years for 600
uh of drugs so whatever reason he wears
tend i think he would be willing to
switch back to that number six he wore
in college
i'll go to davey and clowny put him in
number seven because
really the biggest moment of his
football career came in that jersey when
he popped the guy's helmet off rock em
sock em robot
style and eventually it feels like he's
destined to play for seven different
teams
so it works on multiple levels
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports